hello everyone welcome to another
episode of good gaming news which is a
weekly show where i talk about good news
in video games rather than bad news in
video games because there is enough of
that on youtube already also you might
hear my dog panting in the background it
is hot out here he's just
laying on the floor um and i don't have
it in me to move him okay so there are
actually a bunch of stories this week um
i was like this might be too many but we
can just talk about each of them quickly
the first one being
and i feel very positively about this
elden ring has sold just under 17
million copies in six months this
for fromsoft
is enormous it is tremendous this is um
such an incredible success and far
surpassed uh any industry projections
for elden ring obviously we need people
very excited about it but i would say
this is like from stuff finally breaking
into the mainstream it's not like people
haven't been playing dark souls and knew
what dark souls was for a very long time
but this hits a little bit different it
is huge and i just feel like such a good
sign for single-player games and also
for games that have previously been
viewed as um
having a really difficult barrier to
entry that other publishers can look at
this and take away
the success of elden ring is success
that they can also obtain you just have
to make a good game that's it you can
make a single-player game make a lot of
money you just got to make a good game
so the story from pc gamer says eldon
ring was released on february 25 this
year and just under six months later
publisher bandai namco has announced it
sold a staggering 16.6 million copies of
the game this makes it by far the
biggest individual success in developer
from software's history the dark souls
series has sold a combined total of
around 27 million while the most recent
figure for sakura was 5 million copies
sold as of summer 2020 which is
offensive to me to be honest sakura
is so good
5 million copies
come on now what are you all doing play
sakura okay i bought that game twice all
right
i played it on pc
and i have an xbox save i occasionally
go to
you you're all gonna pick up the slack
the news came as part of bandai namco's
financial results thanks to gamebiz.jp
for the first financial quarter of 2023
meaning april through june 2022 would
show that the japanese giant is in rude
health a reported video game sales
totaling 40.5 billion yen a roughly 55
year-on-year increase with 11 million
units sold over these three months that
is so impressive so so so impressive
yeah like obviously
when you're comparing it to the entire
dark souls
series combined having 27 million
eldering popping off and i'm just really
happy about this it's it's a great game
for a lot of reasons
and uh no micro transactions um it just
feels like a real beacon of
proof that you don't have to
have games as service to sell which you
know just very very happy about it very
well deserved uh what a great game i
hope that almond core rumor is true
big armored court person i know there
aren't that many of us out there
um but yeah very quick news to start
with very positive news feel great about
it congratulations from soft everybody
go by sakura for the next story let's go
with this one right here this has been a
bit wild to watch over the last 24 hours
so basically the news which is only news
at all because somebody reported on a
rumor poorly um which makes it half news
is uh reports ref refute uh this page is
awful reports refute rumors of amazon
buying electronic arts it was rumored
over the past 24 hours that ea was gonna
make a bid sorry that amazon was going
to make a bid for ea at some point today
that that news would go public it did
not that never happened and it seems
like the rumors are totally baseless
which i feel again
very very positively about i do not want
amazon to buy
yay uh frankly i don't want amazon to
touch video games um i have similar
fears as i've had with google in a lot
of cases where it's like they will make
something and then just drop it um when
you have that much goddamn money anyway
and video games are not your priority in
any capacity it just it's just such a
good way for studios to get shut down
yeah i'm also i guess glad that they
they do have studios working on games
but a lot of those have not been
particularly successful i just happy for
you to have your own studios and make
your own tech please don't buy anyone
else i don't want that even ea i don't
want it um so the editor's note is
really the most important part of this
article which
was issued today at 10 37 am et earlier
today glhfa gaming esports outlet and
content partner for for the win ran a
version of this story on our website
that violated our editorial standards
regarding the use of unnamed and
unembedded sources we have updated this
story to remove all mention of those
sources goes on to say though it's been
rumored amazon will soon announce that
it's put a formal offer to acquire
electronic arts amazon is not expected
to make a bid for ea according to cnbc
okay so this is the report from cnbc um
i cut like the first 50 seconds out of
this because these dudes are just like
bantering awkwardly
it's very weird
uh so here's the actual part of the well
it just came down a lot i guess because
of the tease listen i mean i have talked
to some people who would actually know
if there was something going on and they
say there's nothing going on um these
are people who would be involved who in
fact were involved when our parent
company joe was talking to electronic
arts that was real that was some time
ago uh it didn't advance after a while
in part because our parent company uh
entertaining this idea of spinning off
nbcu into ea having the ea gentleman run
the combined company
but wanted voting control so that didn't
happen
ea definitely has been out there a bit
in the past at least considering what it
might do you could imagine amazon might
have some interest but as for this
swedish
um uh report from this good luck have
fun is the name of the uh that's where
the rumors came from uh no this is not
going to uh not going to happen today is
from what i'm hearing unless the people
who've been involved previously have no
idea i would consider um obviously this
is a lot of people being like i know
people are not actually sourcing anybody
which is infuriating when you're talking
about credibility but i would consider
this and it's so funny to see this kind
of video is these are the people that
actually make the decisions in the games
industry it's these two men in suits
talking on
cnbc that is the actual people who have
power in the games industry and we
pretend it's gamers no no no it's these
guys in any case yeah i would consider
this to be more valid than the original
rumor in any case it has also not
happened today but i do think ea going
for acquisition is something that i
actually kind of feel positively about
just depends who i don't want it to be
amazon i don't want it to be apple i
think there are potential partnerships
that could work out really positively
for players um
and i it does sound like they've been
pursuing it so i guess we just gotta
wait and see how that goes but i'm glad
that this rumor seems to be nonsense
amazon is not buying ea
please don't buy anybody
okay next up we have a report from jason
schreiber bloomberg news
this one says troubled star wars a video
game
remake sorry shifts to new studio um
i have spoken about this i think i made
a tick tock news video about this one
this is obviously the the development of
the
remake because office obviously had a
lot of trouble a lot of people just got
laid off it just seems like a real mess
top to bottom and so i was worried about
it being cancelled indefinitely um sorry
it was delayed and definitely and thus i
was worried about it being cancelled um
that seemed like the logical direction
that it would be heading in so taking
the game to an entirely new studio which
is what this report says obviously means
that it's going to be a little bit
further out or way further out that is a
very very difficult thing to do
one of the biggest problems with
something like this in game development
is
you can't just like take the game the
way you were making it and give it to
another studio if the people at that
studio don't have experience with the
exact tools that were being used like
that
this the tools are not transferable
across the board some of them are
depending on the engine but for the most
part like
losing the people
who were working on the project
originally like i said a lot of them got
laid off is a very big blow to the video
game itself so this is obviously a
pretty significant
um
uh
delay is going to come from this
but at least it means that the project
is still being made um for now obviously
i but i do feel like this is probably
going to be pretty permanent and like i
said feel positively about it let me
move my webcam over here
thank you
okay the report says the highly
anticipated remake of video game star
wars knights of the old republic has a
new developer after a bumpy ride the
project formerly in development at
austin texas-based aspire media is now
being led by one of saber interactive's
eastern european studios according to a
person familiar with the change you ask
not to be identified because the details
are private
i hate this too um this is a thing that
drives me nuts uh it happens all the
time and i have had to report things
with an anonymous source before i get it
but
a person is not a very good source
gonna throw that out there a person um
it's not my favorite developers are
owned by the swedish company embracer
group a b which obliquely referenced the
pivot in a public statement last week a
representative for embracer didn't
immediately have a comment the
transition shuts down into lingering
hope within a spear aspire spear i
actually don't know how to say that
studio i've never heard it said out loud
uh that it may be able to continue
leading the project bosses at the studio
which had been developing the remake for
more than two years told staff last
month that the game was on pause as the
company tried to figure out what to do
next bloomberg reported the message left
open the possibility that aspire could
one day reclaim a leadership role but
rumors quickly swelled among employees
that sabre was taking over this is a
positive move from embracer they could
have dropped this project
you get worried about that with these
mass acquisitions um i'm so curious to
see what embrace it does over the next
few years i think it's going to be very
very interesting and i'm going to be
keeping a very close eye on them but it
seems right now like they intend to use
or revive a lot of the ip that they have
as they did as thq nordic right like
that branch of embrasa is the one that
made dark side is three happen um it's
obviously on a lesser scale then or a
smaller scale smaller budget than the
previous games in that franchise but
it's really the only reason it was able
to exist is because thq believed in it
thq nordic that is after they bought the
name thq from previous thq
it's quite a journey but i feel
positively about them so far i don't
like the mass acquisitions but today the
deal finally closed for deus ex and tomb
raider
and that makes me think it's probably
pretty likely that we actually will have
those franchises back which is very
exciting and again this is a positive
move they are not canceling this project
they are just
moving the project which is definitely a
thing you can do when you own a million
studios apparently embracer intends to
recreate the magic of the original
knights of the old republic a
role-playing game that came out in 2003
to great acclaim and update it using
modern technology the game lets players
create their own jedi wield lightsabers
and choose whether to follow the light
or dark side of the force in a galaxy
filled with complex characters and a
rich story embraces that it is not
expecting any material delays due to the
transition
i doubt it bloomberg goes on to say
about the game announced during a
playstation event last year does not
have a public release date and will
likely take at least two more years to
finish yeah i mean we don't really know
in any case i feel positively about this
it means that the game is still being
made i would love to know what actually
happened with aspire media the layoffs
all of that i'm so curious about how
this
happened i just can't even really guess
but glad that the game is still being
made glad that the remake is still
coming out i just really hope it's good
at this point that's where we're at next
up this one is really quick but i did
want to point it out because it's good
news
online features for the pc version of
dark souls 3 have been reactivated
um this is really simple it just says we
are working to restore these features
for all other dark souls titles and
we'll inform you when they are back in
service thank you once more for your
patience and support it's just a regular
update from fromsoft on steam great news
love it happy to see it um i i feel like
this is also probably
just a guess but that
sales for the soul series has probably
increased as a result of elden ring
which
is also awesome i love that for all of
us the last story is one that i feel
positively about but i don't know if
that many people will care about this um
yakuza creator nagoshi says his next
game will be a violent and silly like a
sorry will be violent and silly like a
tarantino movie it's kind of weird
because yakuza is already violent and
silly maybe not that much like a
tarantino movie
but yakuza ah the series has this thing
that i just
love so much which is characters with a
lot of heart
very dramatic almost melodramatic plots
and then just the silliest most
ridiculous stuff in between but it never
actually loses
the threat of that tone it still always
feels like the same game and it's
impeccable direction like the director
who's pulling that off and is being like
this isn't yakuza this is yakuza and
still making that package cohesive when
it's it's just so
extreme you're saving someone who
went blind from
extreme trauma in the same game where
you're doing like a phone sex minigame
like it's just it's incredible um and i
just thought that this this news is
exciting they also say the designer
suggests fans won't have to wait long
for its reveal which is also exciting
yakuza created toshihiro nagoshi has
shared more details on his new game ip
being developed by nikoshi studio his
new studio under netease
speaking of german publication four
players the former sega veteran
suggested that he didn't want to stray
too far from the formula that made the
yakuza game such a success drama
violence and humor you're not wrong of
course i can't reveal too much about our
game yet but i can give a rough idea it
will definitely contain violence as a
game element but i don't want to go too
much in the direction of thriller or
even horror i want my game to be
something more like a quentin tarantino
film so that can be humor something
that's just intimidating or just bloody
and brutal doesn't suit my taste i want
a human touch a bit of silliness and a
bit of seriousness that's what i'm in
the mood for at the moment
awesome fans we get to see the new
project negotiate suggested they won't
have to wait long tokyo game shows what
that means again i have to be vague but
it's like this i have an idea i don't
want to realize it then it soon bubbles
out of me or maybe that is longer maybe
he means next year tokyo game show is
very close though i'm definitely
expecting some yakuza related
announcements there to be honest if not
the type you can hold something like
that back for long so you probably won't
have to wait too much longer or rather i
think it will go public with it much
sooner than other developers would which
is probably going to drive people nuts
negoshi officially announced the
creation of negotiation studio in
january the studio is a wholly owned
subsidiary of chinese company netease
games and will focus on developing
high-end titles for worldwide release
primarily on consoles i'm excited about
it i'm just very glad to hear that it's
still going to be a lot like yakuza and
then it's not like we want it apart from
the series and do something new and it's
like but the series is so good though
keep it up so yeah just so like another
little highlight gem on the end of this
week's good gaming news everybody thank
you for watching i feel like i got
through these ones so fast
um because there are so many and yeah
i'm a day late to doing this this week
because i thought there would be more
gamescom news
but not actually that much to be honest
otherwise i will not have an episode of
this show up next week
probably i don't think maybe i can work
it out but i doubt it because i am
traveling with my dad
so
[Music]
i won't be at my pc here um but
otherwise thank you all for watching
just
thank you for the the dog
what a good boy
i will see you guys next time bye